hi welcome to this round table
discussion
i'm joined by drago radov who's a com
pro
professor of computer science at yale
university and jonathan bisk an
assistant professor of computer science
at the language technology institute at
cmu
we've
had two
brilliant talks by them in which they
both
presented
really interesting research on natural
language processing
and also multimodal
analysis combining computer vision and
nlp
and also in both of their talks they
presented new um data sets and so i
wanted to start there um and a question
to to both of our speakers um based on
those those
data sets that you um
you created what were the main sort of
motivations
and limitations you saw in the current
data sets that that drove you to to to
create those just to summarize
um we'll start with uh draco
okay yeah thank you daniel
so uh our lab is actually quite well
known for generating a lot of nlp data
sets and many of them are really highly
respected so the the biggest data set
that we created a couple of years ago is
called spider
you heard about it earlier today uh it
is currently probably one of the largest
and most well-known data sets in
semantic parsing for database access so
the reason why we created it is that the
current state of the art at the time we
did it 2018 was that there was only one
big data set wiki sql from salesforce
and that was only covering uh single
tables and not joins across different
tables we didn't have any complicated
queries any nested queries any aggregate
queries so uh my student tao you who
recently finished his phd here and
started as an assistant professor at the
university of hong kong
uh created this data set along with 10
other students from the lab and it took
us more than six months to clean it up
and to make it publicly available but
we've been very happy because the
leaderboard on papers with code is
currently teaming with submissions from
all over the place
excellent thank you and jonathan the the
web qa
data set do you mind kind of summarizing
and sharing what motivated you to
to create that
yeah so i think i think that it really
builds a lot on what drago was saying
about this push towards aggregation and
reasoning right so it's this sort of
notion that you want benchmarks that are
requiring that kind of skill set and
then in particular in our context as
opposed to for instance structured
knowledge we're looking at sort of the
siloing that has existed between the
vision and language communities and so
if i have access to information in any
modality i should be able to articulate
it and so it's a question of how do we
move ourselves towards models that are
able to do that kind of aggregation
cross modality
yeah and to build off that um you wrote
in
or you spoke about in the
talk about
you're unifying a multimodal reasoning
model to sort of seamlessly transition
um
between different
different
source modalities like images and and
language
do you think that transformers for
example are somehow fundamentally
limited in the way that they can do that
or are you hoping just to sort of push
that research to
basically
deal with this better no
yeah so it's a it's a really good
question i think that there's i want to
i want to separate two aspects i want to
separate sort of the transformer as a
machine learning framework and then the
implementations of it that we've seen
and so i think that there is perhaps a
fundamental limitation to the way that
it's being deployed
so we i think have historically and i
say historically as in the last two to
three years um seeing this kind of focus
on like getting a vision system to
produce um a pretty small set of natural
language labels and then assuming that
we can sort of reason from there that's
a very limited
notion of the world and it's a very
limited notion of what vision actually
has access to and so the transformer
that we're currently seeing is
oftentimes of that form it sort of take
a pre-trained limited vision system and
then sort of hope that we can do
something with this output there has
been some work in the last year i think
built in some other models like this
which are really starting to change that
paradigm where
vision is a first-class member
alongside language and i think that
really does start to open this question
about like what does it mean to build a
truly multimodal representation have a
single
sort of part of the embedding space
that's both an apple as everything you
would see and also all of the sort of
textual knowledge implications you know
recipes or whatever that you might have
and so that's that's very much the focus
so i wouldn't necessarily say that the
model itself is limited but the way that
we've deployed them hasn't quite gotten
there yet
thanks and and draco um you mentioned
that many people were using your data
sets and the leaderboards were really
competitive
what do you feel are the most um
exciting
you know where's the most exciting
progress coming in in terms of achieving
those results based on on the data sets
that you've released
well not surprisingly uh you know the
most recent transformer models have
outperformed the previous systems by
quite a lot we saw a huge
jump in the quality of the systems
around the time that we submitted our
data set to the website
more recently there have been mostly
marginal improvements and i think that
it's time to wait for the next big thing
that will come out
hopefully i'm hoping something that is a
combination of neuro and symbolic
methods
yeah if i can if i can sort of just jump
on like i think i think this is this is
like the key insight right and drago is
obviously sort of a leader here but um
it's this notion that reasoning is not
necessarily the same thing as sort of
copying or
which is what a lot of these models are
doing um or kind of sort of paraphrase
kind of things where we're sort of
looking for sort of these simple
equivalences in the data if you actually
have to create new data because you for
instance are reasoning across something
then the symbolic representations are
the way that we do it so it you know in
terms of if we're writing it down and so
it seems natural that we would want to
be moving to models that also have that
kind of ability
yeah may i add one more thing so uh the
amount of data that we have is obviously
huge but it doesn't grow at the rate
that we really want to build better
models
there is always a long tail of things
that we have never seen before you know
just once or maybe even zero times i
think that the only way that we can deal
with this long tail is through some sort
of very clever compositionality so that
if you can solve some simpler versions
of the problem which appear much more
frequently and then you find a clever
way to combine them you should be able
to cover
a lot more of the long tail
yeah that's uh that's a really
interesting challenge and i think
even more potentially more extreme in
the case of multimodal these you know
multimodal contexts um
do you
do you foresee they
be in the near term being
more research pushing beyond image and
language and and thinking about um that
there's been some interesting work just
driving models directly from speech data
for example um
jonathan are you exploring any any
modalities beyond um
yeah so so it's so i i it's one of those
things where it's like what i want to do
what's practical what's the sort of like
all these versions of that right but but
i think yeah the one in particular that
i tend to think a lot about is the as a
modality is action
so i think if i can build on sort of uh
drago's comment about the tail there's
sort of the scope of things that have
been written about which is smaller than
the space of knowledge it's you know so
you have the the
scope of things that have been
photographed the scope of things that
have been recorded the scope of things
that have been spoken but that's all
still smaller than the space of all
things and if you have an agent the way
that a human interacts with the world
that can actually explore and sort of
take actions in order to figure out
where its knowledge representation is
too weak um you know you can even
imagine some simple sort of physics
kinds of domains uh that's i think that
piece that's really that's really
missing a sort of curiosity that allows
you to choose but that that kind of
choose your own adventure style model
also brings with it a ton of other
challenges right the beauty of static
data sets is that they are kind of
constrained and we can sort of iterate
on them and things like that the second
that there is this sort of um ability to
change the data that you're seeing you
have a moving target and so that that
transition i think is super important
but also super hard
yeah i completely agree with jonathan
and another modality that we should
explore more as we all know is the video
so there has been a lot of interesting
work in the last few years from the
university of washington and illinois
and microsoft and other places on
exploiting actions that are described in
videos so you just watch somebody you
know cook some dish and then you want to
understand what are the different steps
and how you combine things how do you
prepare you know the final result
that's great and and we we only have a
short time here for this conversation
unfortunately but just want to end on um
you know building off what um you just
said about you know what's
you know you have to sit at this place
where what's you know doing what's
practically possible as well as what's
you know exciting and can drive the
research forward but
say
say you didn't have those constraints um
what would
what would the things that you think
would be most helpful to really push the
state of the art be um both in in
in
you know passing of
databases as well as
sort of
the multimodal analysis
i'll give you a very short and very
probably unexpected answer
uh i really believe that we need some
philosophers
to join this kind of projects who can
help us understand the world in a
different way
to a different lens from what has been
around in the last few thousand years
i'll get my one my one word answer is
robots
um we need embodiment
great well thank you very much jonathan
and drago really appreciate your time
and both of your presentations and for
this this conversation thanks
awesome thank you thank you daniel